tom jones famously said what's new
pussycat
whoa whoa whoa whoa at the time many
believed he was talking to a person
of the female variety about what was new
in their social life
however in light of recent breaking news
it could be that
he was actually the world's first
scooper take that
charles murphy he beat you now if that
absolutely horrendous intro hasn't put
you off
then sit tight and hold on to your butts
because we're going to be breaking down
the new story that says there's
currently a catwoman tv show in
development at hbo max
if you're new here then please smash the
subscribe button as we do videos like
this every day
and don't forget to hit the thumbs up if
you're as hyped as we are
so this report comes from the cinema
spot who within the last 12 hours have
posted a story stating that a catwoman
tv show
set in the matt reeves batman universe
is reportedly in development at hbo max
this comes in the wake of zoe kravitz's
show high fidelity
being cancelled after one season and i
can't even hate
she went and got a brand new job in less
than 24 hours
now last month it was announced that
there was going to be a gotham
central-like show
set in the same bataverse that would
center around the police
department investigating crimes in the
infamous city
we were told at the time that there
would be other projects that matt reeves
would have a hand in
and it looks like this will be the first
of many that will follow on from his
solo batman film
which is due to drop next year now i
can't be bothered writing because i'm
very lazy but the full report says
warner brothers television is currently
working on a catwoman show for hbo max
not much is currently known about this
series outside of the fact that it's set
in the same universe as the upcoming
batman movie
zoe kravitz is expected to reprise her
role as selena kyle
aka catwoman yesterday hulu announced
that their high fidelity series
would be prematurely ending after one
season and while we currently don't know
why this series was cancelled
it is likely catwoman had a hand in its
decision ultimately the cinema spot
decided to wait until the fate of high
fidelity was determined first before
running this scoop
which they apparently knew about months
ago the report says that it is possible
the series will be a prequel
exploring the character of selena kyle
and her adventures that took place
before she met bruce
and most other major characters in
gotham city however
the website does say that they've heard
rumors about how selena might not
actually become catwoman in the batman
and because of this they believe that
the catwoman show could be a sequel to
the movie
following selena's transformation into
the iconic villain
slash anti-hero known as catwoman the
catwoman show will be joining the hbo
max prequel series
focused on the gotham police department
written by the wolf of wall street's
terrence winter
it is currently unknown when either
series will start production
but matt reeves is the batman is
currently set to release on october 1st
2021 so lots and lots to talk about
there
and i actually have my own theory on how
things will go
we know that the movie itself will be a
loose adaptation of the long halloween
and in that we watch as catwoman
investigates her past
and she searches for who a true father
is this actually develops into a
spin-off book called
catwoman when in rome in which she
traces back a family tree
and goes through the titular city to
discover her roots
it also features the riddler who we know
is going to be a villain in the upcoming
movie
and though i don't think that he will be
brought across just for a tv show
the things are definitely there to set
it all up either way
this is brilliant news if it's true and
it looks like we might be getting some
more big announcements like this at dc
fandom
which is due to happen on the 22nd of
august obviously i'll keep you posted
but in the meantime i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the story
and if you're hyped for the show or not
comment below and let me know and
if you're excited for the show then
please drop a thumbs up and if you're
not excited then drop a thumbs down
you can also drop a thumbs down if you
absolutely hate me
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the ending of dc's doom patrol
which is going to be linked after this
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning the mcu infinity saga box set
is leave a like drop a comment and
subscribe with notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or at heavyspoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you been the best
i've been definition and i'll see you
next time take care
peace
you